i'll tell you what
works very well for me
um
that
probably wouldn't if i would only be an
engineer okay
and that is
thinking like a user one of the things
that they learned in optimal for example
which was a marketing company it was
like you're not
building a product for yourself
you're in you're building a product for
a module you'll be taking a product for
it for use
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
hello hello thank you for joining us at
20 minute leaders today i'm with jolie
rosen the ceo of armos cyber security
charlie has over 15 years of technology
b2b management and business development
experience with the bsc major in
communication systems engineering and an
mba from wharton school of the
university of pennsylvania
he is passionate about entrepreneurship
securing cloud-native frameworks and his
amazing founding team
his primary interests are building
products businesses and teams the latest
is a fantastic armor
armor brings promise to cloud native
environments embedding visibility and
security into every workload and
building security products the devops
love
prior to founding armo choli was the
chief strategy officer and startup
company optimove where he built the
go-to market strategy sales department
and business team and raised 20 million
dollars of growth round from israel
growth partners
before that he was a management
consultant in the boston consulting
group and a new product initiatives
director within mdocs building startups
within the company in security
virtualization cloud and big data
[Applause]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for being with me and we're
going to have a fascinating conversation
about security developers in the whole
chain thank you very much
thank you for having me
such a fascinating background all the
way from ben gurion to wharton
mba to
boston consulting group director of
product strategy at i'm docs chief
strategy officer and general manager
opsimov and then uh entrepreneur and ceo
armholm with that with some phenomenal
investors behind you and a really really
interesting
problem that you're solving
and so i hope i captured at least some
of the journey correctly but but the
reason why it was important for me to to
go through it is because
you know you have a lot of different
you've had a lot of different roles
whether it be strategy consulting
research engineering
business and now entrepreneur and so
walk me through a little bit your your
sort of what connects the dots
throughout all these different
experiences
well
you know it's kind of interesting that
i'm i kind of ended up where i should
have started right um
everybody does that to begin with that i
ended up doing it um and i think
you know very very honestly
you know it was just one thing led to
another and they ended up winning
you know a little bit by chance as
everything in life you know um every
step i made
from one point to another made sense at
that point there was an opportunity
something new to learn i was always
looking to diverse and do and don't know
new things
and you know eventually the opportunity
to do your own thing it came up to join
uh two you know remarkable entrepreneurs
and ben and leonbee who are my only
co-founders and while the brains behind
you know this this venture
and
you know just first it was the right
time to do that and that i you know one
of my experience can be actually leading
me into doing this and
you know chances but it's usually chance
right and then the your ability to
actually act on it
so so i'd love to
to to to talk a little bit about rmo and
the founding but then i'm going to ping
pong back to to some of the previous
experiences you've had and how those
play a role in your understanding and
let's start with
simply the strategy behind what you're
doing i mean you're you're in a new
field
today it feels not so new about it but
it really is new you know in comparison
to to the world in tech you're looking
at kubernetes you're looking at devops
security developers and the whole
process what is armo what problem are
you trying to solve here
well what we are trying to establish
is really what we believe is going to be
or is already starting to be the first
you know end-to-end open source
kubernetes security uh been for for
developers and before diversifies to be
more specific because you know
today there is there you know there is a
reason to being specific about it
and
if you think about the strategy it all
started with the devils you know if you
think about
you know when when we just started we
knew we wanna
change things uh for security we knew we
had like my team as probably the best
security and development background and
and we knew we wanted to solve
kubernetes security problems
and we started with scissors that's the
reality
and what happened is that
you kind of like get
it this you know it was so obvious that
every sister would speak with about
credit security
the
immediate reaction is i need to get my
devops team involved i need to get the
development team involved and
um it was so clear
that they
do not grasp that environment in fully
and it was claimed that there is a big
shift that is happening in the market
where therefores specifically
get more and more security
responsibility
and
and and you know that that's when it
clicked and we knew we we need to create
a solution with which is speed for
developers and for devops and from that
minute on
we built the strategy of okay so if
you're looking at devils you know what's
the best way to go about it and and open
source came into mind and doing a
bottom-up approach where the tool is in
the platform is built for developers
that they can try it's a very very
different buyer
um and and the reason i love it
because it's us right we are developers
uh we are engineers we actually and you
know collaborate and and our customers
and users
are much more like us than they used to
be very very practical very very down to
earth very you know
fact-based and engineering based
decisions so if the tour is good if it's
working well that's what we're gonna go
after
and it is a refreshing approach you know
you talked about my history i used to do
b2b sales in a very kind of like
b2b
go to the meeting put
you know put your suit on you know and i
had the tie and everything and you go to
those meetings and then and you sell
and
it is refreshing to drive your product
sell for you and drive buyers who are
actually you know very very
straightforward no type buyers
where yeah so what what does your
product do
you know and um
that's that's actually what writes me
this by this point
and so so we're understanding this at a
high level strategy and and going back
to sort of understand consumer behavior
and how this is playing out into
companies and
the role developers are playing within
organizations and the shift of
responsibility for who owns the
knowledge and security infrastructure
how did your how did your previous
background impact that because it's
beyond just building a good product for
developers you actually have to
understand
the the supply chain or the development
cycle within organizations and see how
you can create a trusted product that
intersects that right
yeah so it really depends how far we go
um but i started as an engineer i always
say that i'm an engineer and a team
businessman to have an entrepreneur and
i think you know that cycle is really uh
what gives me the opportunity to have a
good view of what's happening here and
you know even though it is a very
practical cell it is still a study and
it is still something that you need to
to nurture and you need to have you know
some of the
i'll tell you what works very well for
me
um
that
probably wouldn't if i would only be an
engineer okay
and that is
thinking like a user one of the things
that i learned in optimal for example
which was a marketing company it was
like you're not
building a product for yourself
you're in you're building a product for
a module you've been taking a product
for the foreign user and i think
building yourself and and i am an
engineer
but even if there is many times when
they create a product for engineers
they they think like not as a consumer
but as a developer of the product so
being painted and putting the the
mindset of the customer on the user into
play
i think is that you know it's a huge
advantage for any company who's trying
to go uh with our approach
so for bringing deep dive into armor as
a product
talking to me sort of through the
development lifecycle of a company today
with our mo and how does rmo's presence
uh within a company tech stack impact
anything that has to do with security
with uh
with any with any debugging or review
processes
what does armel actually tangibly do
yeah so um usually the way we get into
into the company is we have a devops
engineer
or a devops leader that cares about
security
and you'd be surprised i think it's a
one of the biggest misconceptions that
sometimes i hear
is developers don't care about security
okay that's just not true yeah they do
care about security uh they just think
about it as engineers uh so they're not
thinking about it is okay what kind of
solutions can i buy they want to build
stuff
and usually they get into our data page
and and they see um a
a project that can help them and in the
development process into actually five
big issues in the development process
and in the clusters uh without adding a
lot of of of burden um you know we pride
ourselves with the the ability to show
your first results and give you value
three minutes after you started working
with us
and that's exactly what happened they
take the two they install it they run it
once they get the report and then the
idea
of albo is to give them this capability
and show them very quickly the value and
then increase
the engagement with with our platform
through more and more functionality so
you you start using us you see what's
wrong with your cluster and then you say
okay but maybe i should also see
how the vulnerabilities in my cluster
connect to those configuration issues
that i found
and you go into our south version and
you find it there and then we bring
those two together so the more
the more users get acquainted with us
they get more and more functionality and
they get a single pair of glass into
everything that is happening in their
cluster and in their development cycle
and this is putting so this is putting
the developers at a unique position
within organizations right and this is i
think speaking to the shift of
responsibility for developers and agency
the developers have today in in bringing
a new product and ensuring the the
healthy life cycle of the company
can you show a little bit from your
perspective what's been happening to to
developer agency within organizations
and and how critical is that for for
armor
well i think
you know devops works defaults are
becoming
um a very key junction
for everything that is happening in the
company um if you think about it they
basically kind of like operand the data
center of the of the company it's no
longer the data center it's it's now now
the cloud it is fully distributed
it is fully automated
um
but then
everything needs to be tied in together
so you know you see
you know even financial responsibility
guaranteed to devops with cnops using
security according to devops you saw
development and operations going into
devops and they are becoming very very
sad one but one of the biggest problems
that they face
is that they are experts in development
and operation but they are not experts
in finance right and they are not
experts in security sometimes
and the magic that those tools really to
them is you know how can you serve the
security function without being a
security expert
so and how can you serve the funds
function without being a finance expert
so the challenge that you know we have
is as people who create tools for those
users is to help them reach that gap
easter eggs you know speak the right
language disturb them become security
expert without being really a security
expert and syllables for finance etc um
so i think it's a very unique position
where the developers and the developer
agency within the within a company
it is becoming you know much more than
just development they start to manage
different functions which are usually
you know moreover even sometimes
logistic functions
and and they need to manage that
so
as as as you're putting in armor into
organizations and you're you're getting
the engagement from developers so
one thing that obviously has been taking
the world by storm is you know product
led growth and the ability for
for developers engineers or any function
within within an organization to come
and bottom up bring in the product use
it have the product to grow with the
development cycle and then create
increased engagement with the
organization through through that
initial hook
how do you how do you see product like
growth as a core part of armor and i'm
sure that this is a guiding factor as
your building on the product
yeah definitely so for that growth is
you know it's basically a a building a
product development methodology that
helps you build the product that users
love while
you you keep testing and you keep using
the data to put in the functionality
that users prefer and it gives them the
most value
um so the way i look at it product-led
wealth is just
a way
um or a methodology to continuously
creating gated with the product and and
get more and more
uh you know in my mind to me and that
you know it's if it's some some people
that
use this word as simply but you need to
get
your users in love with your product
right they need to
to actually um feed that then that it
provides them value that they love it
and that they use it on a daily basis
and that's what we're trying to do
that's what we're getting that's the
type of engagement that we get from our
users and the way you see that it's not
only in usage when when people start to
tweet about your product and you have
unsolicited content about look how this
is how i use your scalp to do this and
that and and users are doing unsolicited
videos and blogs about your products
this is you know
that that's what you want to get when
you do a product like growth now having
said that you know i'm also
um
i think that extremism and being an
extremist is is never uh the right
choice so nothing is one or zero
um so giving me product yet growth it's
not that you don't use sales it's not
that you don't use customer support you
need to
you know
some people are saying you know
everything should be automated your
product is gonna learn and change no i
don't do just that i speak with my
customers i give them calls if i see
someone who's using the product a load i
set up time with them and learn what
they love about the product it's not all
automated it's not all like here put a
credit card and go in it's something
that you need to
you know um continuously nurture and you
mean you still need to speak with your
customers
ugh don't confuse plg
with okay everything is going to be
automated i'm not going to speak with
the customers the product is going to
convert by itself and everything is
going to be completely automated because
i just don't think that's on the reality
ever
right and so you're starting to touch on
on a really interesting topic which is
sort of like the pitfalls of of where
people may go wrong i think that a lot
of the dangers of these
these terms is that it creates a lot of
hype and and it almost no it's not a
shortcut but it but it allows for for
people to think that they can sort of
isolate themselves from some other
strategies and and that they found this
holy grail and maybe it's maybe product
like growth isn't even the right
strategy for their product
as you are
doing it day in and day out and have you
noticed some other non-trivial
non-trivial behaviors or instincts when
it comes to to this type of strategy
that that you've improved on or overcome
over your career
even specifically about photoclip growth
product light growth or or the develop
or or any strategy for the development
life cycle of a product really
well what i've you know
let me tell you what you know i think
there are not many ultimate truths
in the world but one ultimate truth that
i still stick on with
is you can't develop anything without
customer feedback or without user
feedback
and this should be always in your mind
and you can you can you can automate
user feedback right you can uh put
trackers in your product to see
where the users spend most of most of
the time and you start
um
but maybe i'm old-fashioned i still
believe that speaking with the customers
and speaking with the users
is a key part of building any product
now the channel may change right so we
have a discord channel with over 300
people like are using it and we are
engaged with them there you know maybe
five years ago i didn't know what this
world is
okay and
um and today the channels are very very
different
but still the concept of speaking with
the users
listening to the users um is you know i
still think it should be the main
focus of any company developing any
product
and
i want to end uh on a on a different
note so transitioning from
product and product like growth in your
background i want to talk a little bit
about you and understand you know really
you know where you find yourself in all
this right so you know
where does your passion lie is it is it
in that going back to where we talk
about engineering is it in the product
is it in in in being innovative in this
world that's that's that's changing
really really quickly in front of us
where do your passions lie here
so
you know i started
with being an engineer and like doing
this circle where i now
you know built a product that is very
very um engineering driven
i think and i have to admit that was the
that's where my passion started but in
the last year
you know i think that like one of the
major changes that i'm going through and
maybe maybe i'm late to that but this
open source notion
and the you know the power of open
source
the the
the power of the community
they
you know it's exciting to be the
community it's almost like you know and
if you think about only it's almost like
in the movies where you create a cult
right it's it's something that
you know the level of engagement that
you get invented of excitement that you
get from you know growing more and more
users and getting more and more you know
feedback and getting more and more
engagement
and you know the level of creativity
that that you can get when you have a
community and then they give you all
kind of recommendations and thoughts and
actually managing that community
is uh is something which is really
really refreshing and and yet you know
you start to work with people that are
so much cooler than i am you know you go
to kubecon okay and the people who walk
the floor
are not the people who walk the floor
with rsa
or in you know a retail
in in new york while it's uh
it is so you know the stickers that the
guys created you know and the level of
creativity that you need it's
you know you know what it is
let me leave you with that
there is a generation change in the
world right
and you know either front seat to that
generation champion they see those kids
they're not really kids anymore but
those new decision makers new power
houses of people and capabilities and
knowledge and innovation they're so
unique and that that's for me is the
most exciting thing
a lot of people are feeling very old
listening to this now
jolie thank you very much this was so
cool rmo is such a cool company and
congratulations on the fantastic
milestones with fundraising and with
unbuilding and phenomenal product and
and i look forward to continue following
armos journey in our ecosystem and uh
really really great thank you for the
inspiration and stay safe and stay
healthy
thank you thank you so much for having
me it was a pleasure
thank you